hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to dungeon nightmares I
bet a lot of you were thinking that I
wasn't gonna keep playing this but it
was my full intention to play this for
its fullest experience and I don't know
if I'm gonna go ahead and try to finish
this game all in one but I am going to
try to get as far as possible and I do
not know what that entails
okay this map randomly generated map
looks kind of similar to the last one I
did and that is a very slow door hello
fellow name oh is that the thing oh my
god is that the thing right away
thank you randomly generated map I am so
gonna be to blow you later
although I think I might have run my
course on the B to blow jokes or not I'm
just gonna keep making B to blow jokes
into life hey no hey you now mr. steam
no need to do that alright so I'm hoping
that the ha damn it I keep forgetting
that I needed why not
sprint endlessly until I run out of
breath and then fall over and died all
them what happen what happened that it
what happened is happening right now
cannot see out of candles isn't a little
early to go oh oh yes oh yes dear yes ha
ha suck on that game that's what you get
for spawning me right by both the thing
in the exit record time beaten I didn't
see much of knife 3 but that means I'm
gonna get through to the end of this
game much faster oh I am so good at
games and things I can't possibly be
beaten in the next four nights let's go
go go go go go keep moving they know
where you are I know where I am too but
you already told me about that one
alright let's go let's go no time to
waste
oh thank you so much you actually give
me a candle right off that run you're
half
get away was off that note said Wow
I know they all want my incredible
skills we know where you sleep yeah you
already told me that oh good for you
this math looks terribly diverse and I
have no idea where I'm going for the
rest of my life
Oh another candle thank you so much last
time you didn't give me any Oh another
candle you were so nice to me except for
the times when your diabolical and evil
Hauser's those are not so good oh boy
these doors I got that door jump-scare
really freaked me out like also in the
door starts screaming at me not again
goes you hello
No am i alive
no I'm Dre I'm very dead ah you know
night one Wow no night one why I didn't
think that it would kill me and send me
back to the beginning oh you again you
get out of here with your douchiness
alright I guess I guess I'm gonna fast
forward and done made it again get back
tonight for damn it you gotta be kidding
me
what what happened oh oh you just went
to darkness oh I thought I'd died again
jeez you ass oh whoa oh God you fell
over again dot please I know I'm
amazingly handsome but there is no need
oh hi Hey just taking this gold bar and
going home don't mind me oh I am so
gonna take your femur and crack it over
your skull your douche do not do that
again
there's something behind the door what
what's behind the door which door this
door there's no door Hodor
Oh finally finally I found you and let
me guess the exits right here it's right
there oh my god of course of course I
after I have a perfectly easy time
finding the artifact you the first time
I stay it's gonna be a giant douche and
take forever Diana oh thank you so much
Oh oh boy I found out right away no I
just gotta get all the way the exit
which is probably at the very end of
this map I just got to run straight for
it ignore everything and run straight
for it watch out I'll be to blow you
away
who the hell are you think you are
what oh I thought I was dead for a
second that was so long as I'm not I'm
okay thank you for breathing in my ear
there's a Turkish huh oh my god
physics good I couldn't get the map out
of the way so I can run I couldn't see
what Stella good okay I could see me
tableau candle out a new one I'm okay I
got a lot of candles this time and
that's good what the hell is that huh I
can't run this is bad
who's probably mad this is probably very
bad please stop chasing me I really
appreciate some time alone I know we
spend a lot of time together baby but I
need some you know me time to be me and
find out who I am without death without
death would be lovely I'm pretty sure
you're the guy that boned me to death
before so I'm going to kick you in your
bony balls if you ever try to touch me
again what does that know something out
there there's something out there
Oh someone else why sure that you don't
you don't
that's right get away that's right you
better run I'm too tough wait for me at
the secret place I'm not Mary my name is
markiplier it's kind of close Mary plier
I'll be your Mary plier if you can get
me the hell out of here
still dogs had to bury but I'm right
here with my amazing B to blow powers
it's me Mary plier I'm here to save me
son save you by me I seem to have
dropped my ball somewhere if you could
go find him and pick him up for me oh
[ __ ] goddamn the combo vapor are you
dying I have the vapors I must faint
oh no don't no please don't die I'm so
sad ah piss balls an ass no no it's that
bad scratchy scratchy sound hey having
that [ __ ] it is not good not cool but
not cool you wanna you son of a [ __ ]
Gragas asses no stop it stop it with the
combos I don't want none of it I don't
like death of it I've had it up to here
and maybe even here with your ball Oh
finally God that took forever I know I
need to get out that's kind of the whole
objective thingy I would I'm outta
breath cuz I'm so tired I've been
spending all my time blowing the
skeletons and doing otherwise
kill okay [ __ ] you how about you [ __ ]
yourself Joe no no no no you do not
I am getting us outta here no here with
all you balls am I don't go young I
don't know about it I am spinning
seriously with I go where the goddamn
stairs this is Megan ridiculous boy I've
never alone I know they're all after me
lucky charms God [ __ ] hell hey night
two survived isn't that good my voice is
gonna be exploded
she likes to wait around every corner Oh
jokey stand on the corner that she
that's good for her
oh I feel so good about this map all
right you know what I'm not I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna fast forward anymore
even though I wasn't really fast
forwarding before but this straight shot
cuz it's where I started and I know it's
gonna be a giant dick to me if I die
again I'm never playing again cuz I
don't like to do okay alright come on
bring it on you douches I am sweating
quite profusely
if you could see me right now if you
could touch my face you would notice a
lot of sweat coming off of my body okay
come on what awaits me at night sorry I
didn't really see what was there before
it's okay wait wait no wait it's on the
other side of this wall it's on the
other side of this wall I can see the
blue
I know it's on the other side of that
wall I can see the glow I'm taking
advantage of a graphical bug so that I
know where it is this is good this is
good it's good don't you do it I will
eat him no me I didn't get me I knew you
what is that what is that sound to hear
right shut the F up with that no no you
know you lied to me you lied today you
lied to me he said it would be here
there's a there is a glow in this room
what is that rumbly this is only the
beginning
uh-oh maybe it was in the room
immediately adjacent Fred don't you
Johnny don't make me watch me die I
think it might have been in the room
that was right next to me good stop it
with that [ __ ]
good God get here oh come on it's gonna
trap me isn't oh come the F on it's not
here I saw a glow I saw it it Oh
you dick bag of ass yeah yeah that's
more like it yeah goddamn it again again
with this crap
how did I lose her I just gotta go to
this way now oh crap
yep crap hi hi you're so scary
tell you let me tell you how scary you
are like 10 scary
what Arden you want to run that by me
again you want to run that by me again
oh this way whatever whatever whatever
it's all good I'm not stressed
I'm not woke you stop screaming we all
have problems shut the F up I know you
weren't saying anything pony but shut up
anyway tired of your bull where'd you go
sorry shut up God you're giving me
stress unwanted stress unwanted levels
of stress Oh Oh what is happening am i
turning into one of them what the
skeletons are that thingamabob are okay
I'm gonna be lost forever and ever and
ever and ever and ever and ever and ever
and ever and ever and ever in
ever and ever I never I never I never I
never I never why did I have to look at
that fricking painting I knew something
was gonna happen I just didn't know it
instantly kill me and I didn't know that
it would send me back to the beginning I
regret a lot of things that I've done in
this game oh one of which is taunting
the monsters I am a sweaty mess
I should bottle my sweat and sell it on
eBay that would be gross for charity of
course for the children you know no I
never hear you no no no go go go go go
that's their fear there's something
amazing in this room there's something
fun and happy nope but I have a candle
now that's good I'm a candle what the
hell happened this is weird I don't have
a map can't evading complaining I don't
want any please go away
I'd rather not you just what you son of
a [ __ ] game you better let me go better
let me win this good god you ass oh that
was new and I did not appreciate it
I kind of did okay all right okay
married
shut the F up sigh yeah yeah take some
of that you want some more I'll have
more please no please no I don't want to
play the darkness out happy that's good
the doctor can have everything in my
body it can have my body but please
don't take my be two bloopers oh hi you
want a candle I'll be to blow you oh boy
look look that's what I thought that's
what I thought going into a room blind
very good idea in this right good idea
bad good no boy you're told by that'll
certainly help me when I'm dying
got it been almost this map so big can
handle out bigger this
what are you gurgling and say your
stomach gurgling you don't have a
stomach what do you think you're doing
okay I'm out of here
I'm out of here baby no no no you cut
that [ __ ] good that's what I thought I
don't know nothing that's a feeding I
refuse to do the baiting are you fact
but I don't know where the egg today's
young help me there's LBI at all does it
tell me anything at all why do I even
need the artifact
this is a nightmare anyway I wouldn't
look in the mirror was that the mirror
that wasn't the other pain you'd kill me
before you hit every day oh I gotta be
give there's only a few more places
could possibly be AA black but no tired
but I must continue why am I even
checking the chess anymore there's no
reason for me to check the chess
nothing else there could possibly be no
no
I said new you will listen to me when I
say no you listen to me when I be the
blue listen to me cuz I do not know
where I am goo you know where you sleep
I know you know where I sleep that was
made readily obvious way long ago it
ends here I hope not right no not cuz
they got four more nights after this one
or three more after this one it's got to
be in one die why please know how Drive
enough alright
I spent 40 minutes to beat one more
night than I did before
Hey I don't know play again I felt like
I was playing a lot longer than eight
forty four you son of a [ __ ] you
dickbag my throat oh I'm out of halls a
lot of coffee abs so anyway that was
good I cannot escape next time I can't
wait for that you know darling I can't
wait for that I'm really like looking
forward to that but that's gonna wait
okay so anyway god this I am so sweating
huh that was an ordeal that was an
unbelievable ordeal huh anyway so if you
guys want me to play this to the end
which might take a lot longer than I'd
previously anticipated leave a like to
let me know this game is quite awesome
and quite terrifying to be perfectly
honest but it's great so let me know in
the comments below thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more horror games that I've done there's
a big playlist and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
bring it on you spidery piece of myself
I broke it I broke it I broke everything
why did I break everything
yeah bow bow bow bow